in a township called alexandra a wave of
sickness has raced through the community
over the course of the past two weeks
but nobody's calling it omicron
instead the residents of this
impoverished part of johannesburg are
using a more familiar term
the flu
this is musi musee linda can you take me
through the symptoms
um well i've had a headache locked nose
wasn't too runny
i've been coughing
he knows it's covered he tested positive
last week but moussey doesn't seem too
concerned
on a scale of one to ten for severity
a four honestly before because it wasn't
that dead
the omicron variant was first identified
by south african scientists and the
people who live here are now
experiencing it
and its infectious nature is clear
alexandra's local councillor says it's
moving at an astonishing speed
very fast
very fast like a bomb have you got a
sense for how many people have been
infected here
a lot of people i mean on a daily basis
i interact with around 100 to 200 people
and i talk to a whole lot of them and
and and via what's up via phone calls
some come straight direct to me and a
whole lot of those people admitted the
maturity of them that they have flew
thousands of those people majority of
those people were all saying that they
flew
the consequences of an illness caused by
omicron are less clear
some here say the symptoms aren't that
serious
others don't seem to care to us it's
like stressful because it's raining and
it's cold we think it's
that's all it is so people aren't really
taking it that seriously
even now see i'm not dwelling in my mind
omicron may be classified as a variant
of concern but that doesn't mean much to
the residents
as far as most people here are concerned
there's a bad case of flu going around
and if they get it well they'll get over
it they're cool let me have a look at it
once it's done i'll do that okay thanks
when it comes to the new variants real
world behavior dr fareed abdullah
probably knows more than anyone hi there
it confirms my picture all the time
hey this is not what we had before we
found him in the capital pretoria
staffing the hospital's covet assessment
center and he told us they're seeing
fewer people admitted with the most
severe symptoms
yeah so right now we have 40 patients
either covered positive or waiting for
their results
but the difference this time around is
that the majority of these patients
are not here because of a severe covered
pneumonia
most omicron patients spend fewer days
in hospital and he says they're less
likely to require oxygen or ventilators
so the picture could change
but you know what certainly is that
there is a difference
this time around compared to the
previous three waves
you can say that with some confidence
there is
there is a difference
after several weeks of mass infection
omicron has shown its cards
although the country's hospitals and
clinics have managed to cope
but if the numbers have infected
continue to rise they may struggle to
deal with the consequences